[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast I'm Greg and I'm Lindsay and we
have another great show for you today um
but on this episode I think we're going
to deviate from our normal formula and
skip the plugs and intro banter we
typically do at the top of the episode
because we have some important updates
and announcements here at the top of the
show so let's uh let's dive right into
it so I just wanted to give all of you a
heads up about where things are at and
where my head is at and where Stronger
by science is going in 2024 for and
Beyond after reflecting on some of the
things that have gone well and some of
the things that haven't gone quite as
well uh over the past year or two so if
you follow our content elsewhere like if
you subscribe to the newsletter um or
just follow what we post on the website
you'll be aware of quite a bit of this
already if you just listen to the
podcast some of this may be new um and
you might be wondering why we had uh a
few weeks off this fall um the reason
for that is we were looking for a new
podcast editor which was discussed in an
article on the website um but yeah so if
you just listen to the podcast uh we
published an article in November titled
the future of Stronger by science which
will be linked in the show notes and
would probably be useful to read uh for
full context but the basic takeaways of
it were number one um I have a bit of a
tendency to let myself get stretched Way
Too Thin and that had been progressively
happening again um to the point that it
kind of came to a head this fall into
this winter um and when that happens
it's not good uh my my quality of life
suffers and more importantly I think
just in general I know that's not more
importantly well it's more important for
the people listening to this fa and I
think they also care about you though
well I think
it's I think this next thing I'm going
to say is more important because there
are you know depending on on the
platform and the piece of content we put
out whatever somewhere between tens and
hundreds of thousands of people that
engage with our content and there's just
one of me so you know if my quality of
life suffers a little bit but things are
better for everyone else in a
utilitarian calculus you know maybe
my quality of life isn't the most
important thing whatever no we're not
getting into that today yeah but anyway
so when I let myself get stretched Way
Too Thin my quality of life tends to
suffer and more importantly the quality
of my work tends to suffer as well um
and yeah just a lot of things had been
adding up uh over the past couple of
years so uh until until quite recently I
was responsible for virtually all of the
stronger by science content that
includes the podcast articles research
spotlights Etc um maintaining
interactions in the Facebook group and
subreddit uh virtually all of our
content for macro factor and an
increasing number of administrative
tasks as well and I kind of let all of
that stuff accumulate instead of trying
to get help because I'm kind of wired to
just want to do everything myself MH and
not necessarily because I'm a control
freak like I just find it almost rude to
ask someone else to do something uh even
when I'm paying them to do it and that
is especially true for things that I
tend to find unpleasant yeah um like if
if I'm going to Outsource something I
generally Outsource the things the
things you like that that I like to do
because it's like well this this is fun
so like I don't I don't mind asking
someone else to do something that's
enjoyable
if I don't like I don't want ask else to
do it cuz no I understand that that's
tough though uh but yeah so that that uh
had been happening for for quite a while
um and I think I think that had just
kind of gotten to the point that I
finally was forced to realize that it
was becoming somewhat absurd and
counterproductive so like the first the
first hire that we did was for a podcast
editor uh shout out to real Cy if you've
liked how the last few episodes have
sounded uh that is his doing I think
he's been doing great work but yeah like
you know I I had taken over editing the
podcast which I didn't like doing I
didn't think I was that good at and it
was taking me like three or four hours
every time we put out an episode and I
was like I got a lot of stuff going on
you know like I should hire someone else
to do some else who specializes in that
yeah yeah uh so the next thing and in
kind of building on point1 of the
takeaways from that article was just
that I felt like the quality of our
content had slipped a bit um and and the
reasons for that are discussed in the
article but basically a lot of it just
comes down to how constraints had had
changed over time so back in the day
back back when I think kind of the
golden age of Stronger by science
content was in maybe like 2015 to 2017
thereabouts um I was coaching some we
were selling the ebooks I think we were
selling a program at the time but we had
a very simple operation and you
know there wasn't that much I needed to
worry about on the business side of
things yeah so when it came time to
write an article I could just pull up a
blank document and
devote like not an exaggeration between
like 20 to 40 hours per piece of like
free content we put out which is great
like that's that's what I loved being
able to do and you were able to do that
quite often because it was your number
one focus and you had the time to devote
so we published a lot of Articles during
that time yeah um yeah both both like
the quality and quantity of the output
was very good um and and a lot of it was
just because I had a schedule that
allowed me to do that yeah and as the
number of Demands on my time have
increased I've kept trying to do as good
as I can for both the quality and
quantity of of the content um but yeah I
mean just just constraints dictated that
I couldn't put as much time into things
anymore and when I did try to put a lot
of time into stuff instead of it being
something where for just you know a week
or two straight it was the only thing
that I had to focus on and all of my
focus like you know when I when I would
lay in bed at night I would be thinking
about whatever article I was working on
and now you know not only are there
actual time constraints there are other
things um vying for my attention yeah
and so yeah like I I just think that um
I've continued to do the best that I
could but just as a natural result of
some of the increases in
responsibilities I've had I do think
that the quality of our content output
has slipped a bit um and number three uh
in terms of takeaways from that article
was that due to the combination of
administrative and content demands I had
I think I was falling short on both
fronts so talked about the the slipping
content quality
a bit but you know those those two
things like there was quite a bit of
interplay there where when I did need to
focus on content it was typically
because I was already behind on
something where it's like oh had a
deadline yeah yeah it's like oh my God
like I've been doing I've been doing
like administrative stuff and like
business stuff and we need to record a
podcast tomorrow I have not even started
outlining it yet so instead of instead
of being able to kind of ruminate and
marinate in a topic for a week or two
it's like okay I got 24 hours like let's
let's try to put together the best
podcast we possibly can in the next 24
hours just starting from scratch um and
then there's a research Spotlight that
needs to get published and need to get
an article out and need to get an
article out for macro Factor as well so
you know let's try to get all of that
done over the next like 2 days and then
I would basically have to turn just
everything off like all distractions for
that time to get all of that done which
was fine I'd get it done it would still
be of of decent quality but then when I
would look at my email again I'd be two
or three or 4 days behind on [__] and
then it's just kind of like a Mad Dash
rush to try to get caught up there and
you know I'm I'm trying to get caught up
but in a way that's just checking like
checking boxes instead of being able to
actually like think deeply about the
stuff that I'm doing um and then you
know by the time I was caught up and
maybe a little bit ahead I would then
once again be in a crunch for the next
content that needed to get out and so it
just burnout Cycles like cuz you would
do those big pushes for content and then
you'd be so burn out but you'd be behind
on other stuff so then you would
immediately kind of have to jump back in
even though you needed some time to rest
yeah and it was just that over and over
and over again yeah so I I was I was
working as hard as I could and doing as
good as I could and not doing the best
that I would be capable of in either
domain really um and yeah it just that
feels like [__] yeah like it it was
that's a bad feeling it wasn't a good
thing so uh to be clear like I'm not
just here like self flating or fishing
for compliments like I know I've been
doing like Pretty good overall like I I
have still been pulling my weight in the
businesses um I do think that the
content we've been putting out is not up
to the extremely high bar that I I'd set
for myself like I do I do still think
it's been pretty good it's Prett good
I'm not trying to say like ah everything
I've done in the last two years has been
[__] you have an incredibly High bar
yeah but it's it's like I think it's
been good but I shoot great you know and
that's what makes it feel meaningful and
worthwhile to you correct yeah like I um
I I do get like a very immense sense of
satisfaction from doing my very best and
putting my very best work out there and
on the flip side like this is just a
weird little thing about me like when if
I feel like I owe someone something and
I don't do the best I possibly can and
give giving it to them uh even even if
it's like acceptable uh I feel like very
guilty about that it's probably like
Protestant up stuff what you got all
kinds of protestant [__] yeah like that
that is just how I feel so you know like
I like I I do think the content we've
been putting out is good like I feel bad
often times when we publish it cuz I'm
like I know it could have been better if
I had like three times as much time to
work on it y um so yeah like
basically it it just hasn't been working
for me all around like I was severely
overworked and just very dissatisfied
with the work I was doing um yeah so
just uh o overworked feeling bad etc etc
um put out that article just kind of
laying out yeah letting people know
what's going on yeah letting them know
where things were and what things would
need to change um but we've been working
on the changes we have yes so so we we
have made some changes already and we're
in the process of making some more and a
lot of those changes come down to hiring
uh because I've been trying to do the
jobs of five or six people and so that
means we probably need to hire four or
five people you
know so uh like I like I mentioned
already we have already outsourced
podcast editing once again uh shout outs
to real um we've brought on quite a few
new moderators for the Facebook group
and subreddit and they're already in
there absolutely crushing um we've hired
a full-time content person for macro
Factor uh that being Lee Peele shout out
to Lee amazing um she's been great so
far and if you've been in the fitness
industry for a while like you know Lee
and I'm
honestly flumix that we were able to
hire her in the first place but yeah so
uh that's going very well and and um
we're looking into hiring some folks to
help with some of the administrative
tasks that had piled up for both
businesses that had kind of fallen on
both of us um and now on the stronger by
science side of things as it relates to
you dear listener um we are bringing on
Milo and pack to work with us fulltime
uh there is a reason that they were the
guests on the last two episodes of the
podcast I figure I figure a lot of
people in the stronger by science
audience would be pretty familiar with
them already but uh you know wanted to
go ahead and and formally introduce them
to you guys uh on the podcast uh by the
time you're listening to this they will
have already started maybe like a week
week and a half ago or so um but yeah so
I don't know how many people who listen
to the podcast read our emails follow us
on social media so just announcing it
here so you know uh as well and um so
yeah we're we're really really excited
about that and just personally I don't
know if I will ever personally get back
to the point where I can spend 90% of my
time and brain power on making truly
exceptional free content um but Milo and
pack are both very very smart and very
very talented and they will will be able
to devote the vast majority of their
time and brain power to making truly
exceptional content and I have
absolutely no doubt that the two of them
plus myself to the extent that I am able
to focus on content and contribute to it
I I have no doubt that we will be able
to uh not only return to the Golden Age
of Stronger by science content but uh
exceed the prior bar that we had set for
ourselves um both in terms of quality
and quantity of the output and I am
extremely excited about that uh so uh a
bit of an announcement for the podcast
is this will be the last Lindsay and
Greg episode um Milo and Pac will be my
co-hosts starting next episode um and I
think you are also not
that upset about not co-hosting
anymore yeah I'm not that upset about it
I mean a lot a lot was in flux last year
as we tried to sort all this out the
stuff that you've talked about and just
try to
re-evaluate where we want Stronger by
science to go and what we want it to
look like and how we can do the work
that feels the most meaningful to each
of us you know we've been doing this for
over 10 years now um but all that was in
flux but we still wanted to keep
releasing podcast episodes cuz the
podcast like kind of surprised us with
how big of an audience it grew and how
devoted the audience was and just how
supportive and great everybody has been
so even though we are trying to figure
[__] out we still wanted to release
episodes of the podcast didn't want Greg
to have to do it by himself so I jumped
in here as the co-host and it's been fun
like I really have had fun recording
these episodes with you it's the first
time I've ever done anything so public
with Stronger by science um usually I'm
completely behind the scenes um so I
really really appreciated the support I
received from our
listeners but I'm not an expert in this
stuff uh I enjoy talking about it and
learning but now that pack and Milo will
be working with us I'm definitely
excited to hand over the mic to them
they're both researchers in this field
and they're professional science
communicators they are going to have so
much more to contribute to the
discussions on this podcast than I did
even though I enjoyed what I could do
you you crushed it on the aspartame
episode honestly like I it almost killed
me I I do think that that's the best
episode of the podcast we've ever done
and I I think a lot of that was due to
your uh your journalism chops that you
brought to bear on it thanks yeah and I
I had a lot of fun doing doing an
episode like that that I could research
really heavily and have a lot to say but
that's just not something that is in the
cards most weeks you know like I
probably spent 20 hours prepping for
that podcast and I just can't do
that like I have other responsibilities
with my work and the podcast um it
doesn't make sense for it to be a
primary focus for me because it's it's
truly just not where my my expertise is
but the asart tame episode was
definitely a highlight and um that was a
real test to see who the true heads in
the audience are who's going to listen
to us talk for six hours um I'm I'm
amazed that anyone did
honestly but uh anyways pack and Milo
they're going to have they're going to
have a lot more to contribute on an
episode to episode basis I think um
because they are in the trenches on this
stuff so as they step in I'll be
stepping back into the role that I've
had with Stronger by science for 10
years now which is just the behind the
scenes project management the marketing
the editing the design um I'm excited to
get back to it I I had fun in my short
St as a podcaster but it's time I got
back to focusing on the things that I
think I'm really good at and I know I'm
leaving it in Great hands and that you
and pack and Milo are going to have so
much fun and I'm I'll keep listening and
I'll be around I I think I think your
great curse is that you're too good at
too many things like the the main things
you do for the business you're
exceptionally good at I do think you
have also been very good on the podcast
um and so a lot of people will will miss
you and hate to see you go but I'm I'm
happy for you that you can you can hand
it over because I I I know that you did
have a bit of like fear Intrepid I'm an
extremely private person um I don't
really want people knowing anything
about
me or being like a public person on the
internet it's it terrifies me so yeah
definitely much more comfortable uh
behind the
scenes well uh I will I will miss
co-hosting with you I was going to say
I'll miss you but we live together we'll
keep seeing other we just don't have to
do this together anymore yes but I I I
have I have really enjoyed this um but I
am also very excited about the next
chapter as well and uh dear listener I
hope you are too so in two weeks time uh
it will be myself Milo and pack uh back
with the stronger by science podcast so
hope hope you'll stick around and and
give it a list
yeah so with that out of the way let's
uh let's hop into the content here yeah
we got a full Q&A episode today this is
a Q&A episode yes and uh if you were a
member of the Facebook group and
subreddit you would have known that and
uh would have been able to submit
questions to the podcast uh if you're
listening you're like damn I have great
questions that I wish would have been
answered and I didn't know that this
would be a Q&A episode guess what check
out the subreddit reddit.com r/r
Stronger by science or Stronger by
science community on Facebook so when we
do have Q&A episodes you'll know and you
can get your questions in um but yeah
with with that out of the way let's get
into the questions uh we have a few
audio questions that people submitted to
podcast at Stronger by science.com we
have several from Facebook and several
from Reddit and uh let's start with at
least most of the audio questions first
so here is the first one from
Tio hey Greg a quick one for mind when
it comes to researching relatively
unfamiliar topics let's say the impact
of collagen on skin aging or maybe air
pollution on health do you have some
sort of research framework you follow
when tackling stuff like that
cheers so that question how do you go
about researching a whole new subject
this is this is interesting I'm
interested to see what your answer is
cuz you do you do know way too much
stuff and I just don't know how you're
getting all that stuff in your brain and
when uh yeah so it it's a it's a
multi-step process and the first step is
simply assessing whether it's something
I actually need to understand on a
granular level and more generally kind
of scoping out how well I need to
understand something
period um and also scoping out whether I
have the time to devote to it in order
to learn and understand it on a
particular level um and a lot of that is
based on relatedness to things that I
already know quite well um and yeah and
just like how well I need to understand
the topic so uh the two examples that
Tio provided there were um the effect of
of collagen on skin and the impact
of pollution on health like air
pollution on health and of those two um
I would say that if I would need to
understand one or the other I would
probably need to understand the effects
of collagen on skin because that's more
closely related to some of the things we
talk about um and learning something
about that may have tangible benefits
for other things that I might be
interested in so you know I I might be
interested in the impact of collagen on
tendons or ligaments or bone health
potentially uh as it relates to exercise
um and if collagen is is impacting like
if collagen supplementation is impacting
skin that would also be due to collagen
synthesis there there would probably be
some overlapping Pathways there so you
know it it might be hoov me to learn
about that and since we talk about
supplement some and collagen
supplementation is popular
uh some people take it for you know
muscular connective tissue related
reasons but a lot of people take it for
skin related reasons you know it it
might it might behoove me to try to
learn a lot about that um so you know I
I might say hey this is something that
if I'm going to learn about it I should
learn about it quite well but I might be
able to pick it up at a high
level quicker than other things because
I do already know some stuff about
collagen synthesis and connective tissue
Health um so yeah that would be you know
the first step of screening versus the
impact of of air pollution and air
quality on health I don't know I don't
know lung stuff quite as well honestly
um you have famously bad lungs I do have
famously bad lungs for if on a selfish
level it probably wouldn't yeah maybe
you should maybe you should
but it's that's far enough from my area
of expertise and the stuff I talk about
that like if I wanted to to learn a
little bit about it I I would be fine
being able
to like learn learn a a little about it
so if someone was just like hey how much
does air quality matter I could just be
like yeah yeah if air quality gets bad
enough like it's G to [__] you up in
like some of these ways maybe but you
know I I wouldn't need to know all of
the details about it
um but since that is less related to
things I already know about getting a
moderate level of understanding about
that question would probably take me
about as long as getting a you know
close to expert level of understanding
about collagen and skin that makes sense
so yeah that's kind of the first thing
try to figure out how much do I need to
know and how long do I think it would
take me to learn this um step two is if
it's something that I do think I need to
understand
really really well like all of the ins
and outs um I'm going to look to see if
I can find a textbook about it
and um you know most of the time I'm
going to purchase those textbooks uh I
would never pirate a textbook but there
are
places textbooks are expensive and I've
heard that there are places that
interesting one can maybe find
especially like older editions of
textbooks for free um
and you know we don't we don't condone
that but uh the answers are out there if
you're willing to look
conspiratorial uh but but yeah like if
if I do need to know something really
really really well um especially if it's
a brand new topic that I don't have good
like Baseline knowledge about already um
often times I'll start with a textbook
um and sometimes two textbooks like if
if it's a big enough topic where there
would be like an undergraduate textbook
that kind of acquaints you with the
topic and then like a graduate level
textbook that would like a lot of
graduate level textbooks are essentially
just a series of narrative reviews
written by experts in the field that go
more into specific research findings
like more granular mechanisms so
depending on yeah just like depending on
how well I need to know something maybe
just like kind of the undergraduate
level textbook to get my feet wet maybe
both just to get like super well
acquainted with something and I'm not
going to pretend like when I get a
textbook about a topic that I'm going to
need to put content out about a week
from now that I read it cover to cover
every single word but like yeah like if
if you've done like some skimming and
speed reading like yeah you are a
history major in undergrad for quite a
while you know how to skim and speed
read yeah that's that's true most most
that superow most of history coursework
is just getting pretty decent at speed
reading yeah um but yeah so so step two
if necessary is start with textbooks and
then step three or step two if I'm not
going the textbook route um is actually
getting into the literature and that is
generally going to start with looking
for two specific types of reviews um I'm
generally going to look for systematic
reviews Andor meta analyses that focus
on outcomes and I'm going to look for
reviews which will typically be
narrative reviews that focus on
mechanistic underpinnings of whatever
the phenomenon is um and this is very
important I look for them and I read
them in that order uh outcomes first
then mechanisms and the reason for that
is there's a lot of stuff that looks
really good and like in a Petri dish or
in like rodent research where like they
knock out a Jee to like test the
mechanistic impact of like some
particular protein or enzyme on some
outcome um that ends up like not really
panning out in practice but like the
mechanistic story can be very very
compelling um and I think that if you
start with
mechanisms that can lead that that can
color the way that you view outcome
based research in a way that that would
lead you to to Veer from a Rel L like
strict empirical path which is what I
tried to stick to um you know like if if
there's a compelling enough mechanism
and in the outcome based research
there's a lot of null findings you could
be like oh well that mechanism is so
compelling like it must just be a
problem with like dosage or the
population they did or like how long the
studies ran whereas like if you start
with the outcomes that helps keep you
grounded where you can be like hey look
based on all of the ways that people
have tried to tack this thing before it
maybe seems to be very effective maybe
it seems to have a small effect maybe it
seems to like there's a lot of null
results you know like it it it gives you
good grounding in terms of like actual
longitudinal findings what do we see
when this when this thing is implemented
um and then if there are compelling
enough mechanisms once you've once
you've started with the outcomes then
you can think about it a little bit more
where it's like hey what what like other
competing Pathways may have made this
mechanism not pan out in practice you
know um but anyway yeah so so two
different types of reviews outcome based
reviews mechanistic based reviews start
with the outcomes before diving into
meting yeah that's cool um and then uh
and then the last thing or like the last
couple of things would be if there's
still any like basic physiology that I
don't understand after getting this far
down the rabbit hole I'll just try to
read up on that a little bit more which
like usually that's usually that's like
a standard bio Kim ref um because I mean
there there's by the time by the time
you're getting into published literature
on a topic research is written for
experts in the subfields that care about
that research and so there will be there
will be a lot of things that are just
taken as wrote that don't have to be
explained in every paper
right and so if you're not if if this is
like your first exposure to like an
entire field of physiology you don't
have the foundations correct so so um
with like the with the example of air
pollution and lung Health like
there's I mean I think I think that it's
almost a matter of like unknown unknowns
like I don't know that much about the
lungs and so I couldn't even like make a
list of of just like physiology stuff
that I don't know that well about the
lungs but like you know I'm I'm sure
that there's Stu related to just like
the gas exchange between the Alvi and
the pulmonary capillaries that like I
just that wouldn't be covered in studies
on the topic they just assume you know
that yeah because everyone who's doing
lung Health like would know that like
the back of their hand but like I might
need to learn a little bit more about
that stuff to understand some of the
mechanisms discussed in the reviews that
I that I previously mentioned um so yeah
read up more on basic physiology if I
feel like I couldn't just fully chart
out step by step by step how this thing
is working um and then if
relevant uh I'll dig into some of the
individual studies in the outcome based
uh systematic reviews and meta analyses
like if you're seeing different outcomes
in different populations and I'm
specifically interested in something in
a particular particular population I
might then you know if there's a meta
analysis with like 30 studies but only
seven of them are in the population I'm
particularly interested in then I'll
just go ahead and download those seven
studies in that population and read all
of them um and by that point I'm pretty
close to the bottom of the rabbit hole
and if there are still things that are
unresolved like maybe there's some
conflicting findings between research
papers that uh based on my
like relatively new understanding of
this stuff as I've been learning about
it that that I can't quite reconcile yet
I might see if I can find um some
experts on the topic and bounce
questions off of them who are often the
people doing research in the field um
and often times like researchers like
getting questions about their research
like I think yeah they should you should
ask your questions to researchers
instead of random people on the internet
uh I wasn't going to say that but yeah
probably so oh my God the the number of
emails I get where someone just like
sends me a study and they're just like
hey why did they do this I'm like
there's a there's an email address for
the corresponding author right there
like they would know why are you asking
and they love to get emails um Greg does
not love to get more emails he has
enough I he has enough emails I do get a
lot of emails but yeah like there there
are there are a very very small minority
of like famous academics who have
flooded inboxes and press wanting to
talk about their research all the time
that who knows maybe they're not going
to respond to a little guy who just has
a technical question about a paper they
did four years ago but most studies are
never read like by hardly anyone um so
sad
and academics work really hard and they
they care about their stuff and they are
mostly uh labor away in complete
anonymity and if you have like a good
question about a study that they did or
just their topic of research and you say
hey I read your paper one they're like
holy [__] someone read my paper yes and
two you care about it enough that you
have a follow-up question they're
they're typically going to be pretty
willing to to help you out there and
they know it better than anyone I mean
they'll they'll certainly know it better
than you mhm or likely better than me um
so yeah that's that's kind of like the
very last step like once once I've
gotten through what is published and I
still feel like I don't understand
something it's like hey I'm I'm going to
ask one of the folks who's you know i'
I've been trying to learn about this
thing for two weeks they've been
learning about it for two decades
they're really deep in the muck um they
they their understanding will be kind of
more colored by just like experiential
Knowledge from like living in the field
and doing research on the topic um so
yeah like if if I get to the bottom of
what is published and I still don't know
stuff ask experts to see if they can
help fill in the rest and uh that's my
topic or that's my uh that's my process
and I'll also note just in terms of what
to
expect
I I think a lot of people are hoping
that there is a sort of like fast trck
process to get to a truly expert
understanding of a topic in in kind of
like a hacked way like in a accelerated
way yeah and I do think that if I I do
think that if you go through the process
I laid out and you know really really
devote yourself to it I think you can
get to
a greater than undergraduate level of
understanding of a topic in about two
weeks which is a lot faster than going
through school for like four years but
yeah so much faster you you to be very
clear will not have expert level
knowledge about any topic going through
this process in any like reasonable
amount of time like true expertise takes
years to develop no matter how
efficiently you try to go about
developing it um so I I would say that I
would say go go through the process I
just laid out and that's still going to
take you time like what I just laid out
that is a depending on the level of
depth you're trying to get with
something and and how much like
pre-existing knowledge you have about
related topics it's going to it's going
to take somewhere between like 10 to 40
hours like it's a big time
investment um but I I think that that
will get
you 80% of the way to understanding
something pretty well like this that
will get you to the point where you
might be able to be conversant with an
actual expert on the topic but and then
you can learn more yeah but but don't uh
you know don't don't let the like o
overconfidence of like knowing a little
bit
um convince you that really diving into
something for two three four weeks has
actually made you an expert like you're
you're now like sub dumbass level on the
topic
but you're not you're not that slick
next question next
question okay our next question is from
John hey here's my question so just how
badly does insulin resistance and
diabetes affect hypertrophy one of my
favorite bodybuilding channels on
YouTube just posted a video that seem to
suggest that muscle growth is pretty
much off the table for someone with type
2 diabetes so does the science support
this is it a sliding scale where someone
with pre-diabetes has greater muscle
growth potential than a full-blown
diabetic and finally what is your
opinion on whether metformin impedes
hypertrophy I've never heard this
particular thing before but it does feel
similar to something you've talked about
before weren't there things about
insulin sensitivity
mentioned in the ptio discussions and
the article series from a few years back
is this related to that it is it is yeah
that that was um insulin resistance was
one of the things that we discussed in
that article Series so um just for for
people listening who are maybe newer
listeners and haven't been around when
when was the whole ptio Saga was that
like 18 months ago or so 18 months years
thing to me anymore who knows yeah I'm
not totally sure but um essentially
there there's this
idea that that goes around that was
really popular a couple years ago I
think it's waned in popularity I'm sure
a lot of people still believe it um but
basically the idea is that higher body
fat levels make it harder or you know
depending on who's talking about it
maybe impossible to build muscle um and
so you know couple years ago
uh Eric and myself had a little back and
forth uh with with some proponents of
that idea um I just looked up the date
it was three years ago three Jesus
Christ man yeah I have no concept of the
passage of time um anyway so yeah the
the idea that that um it's harder to
build muscle at higher body fat levels
one of the reasons that people said that
was related to insulin sensitive
the idea that as body fat levels get
higher insulin sensitivity Goes Down And
if your insulin sensitivity isn't
sufficiently high you'll be unable to
build muscle um and so yeah for for
listeners who weren't around for that
Saga you can you can read the articles
dive into the research um it was like I
said more focused on body fat levels
than insulin sensitivity or type 2
diabetes um but the two things are
pretty closely closely related um and
yeah so it doesn't really seem like
higher body fat levels imped your
ability to gain muscle nice um and I do
think that that that that overall
takeaway does probably extend to the
specific qu question about insulin
sensitivity that uh higher insulin
sensitivity probably doesn't make it
inherently easier to build muscle and
vice versa lower insulin sensitivity
probably doesn't make it um certainly
impossible to build muscle or if it
makes it harder to build muscle probably
the effect is relatively small um but
yeah so instead of just leaning on the
the p ratio stuff from a while back um I
did want to dive into the research um
looking at the impacts of of uh
resistance training on diabetic
populations in particular to make sure I
was giving a good answer to this
question
and there was a 2020 review by aosta
menzano and colleagues uh that will be
linked in the show notes the title was
beyond General resistance training
hypertrophy versus muscular endurance
training as therapeutic interventions in
adults with type 2 diabetes malius a
systematic review and
metaanalysis and um so yeah it it looked
at um the impact of resistance training
on a variety of outcomes in diabetics um
um unfortunately only four of the
studies were particularly looking at
changes in lean body mass like there I
think there were close to 40 studies in
this overall review but uh only only a
pretty small handful of them were
looking at kind of outcomes that were
related to hypertrophy but in those four
studies the uh pulled increase and lean
body mass that was found was 71 kg or
about a pound and a half which is
notably more than zero um which would
imply that it doesn't make it impossible
and so you might be wondering okay 71
kilos increase in lean body mass in
resistance training studies and
diabetics how does that relate to
findings in non-diabetics and so in the
same year 2020 there was a metaanalysis
by Bonito and colleagues uh also will be
linked in the show notes the title was a
systematic review with meta analysis of
the effects of resistance training on
whole body muscle growth in adult
males and uh so in that metaanalysis in
healthy non-diabetic adult males um what
they found was about a 1 and A2 kilo
increase in fat-- free Mass lean body
mass um after about an average of 10
weeks of training so even if you took it
at face value that would imply that type
2 diabetes might reduce rates of muscle
growth by about half so you're seeing
about 1 and a half kilos and
non-diabetics about7 in diabetics um so
yeah if you just compare those two
numbers you would say yeah if you're if
you're diabetic you might build muscle a
little bit slower but you know we're
talking about a a reduction of about 50%
or so rather than stopping hypertrophy
entirely um but also the stud studies in
diabetics were typically done in older
adults and also typically used less
intense lower volume training
interventions okay both both of which
would also tend to lead to less muscle
growth right like you know if if you
just said hey we're going to in
non-diabetic populations we're going to
do young healthy folks and we're going
to train them pretty hard um and we're
going to do also resistance training in
older also healthy folks but they're not
going to train quite as hard the
difference in lean body mass observe
like the 7 versus 1.5 kilos you might
still see that same difference um
regardless of of diabetic status so I I
do think just comparing the outcomes of
these two metaanalyses probably if
anything overstates the impact of like
the negative impact of type 2 diabetes
on hypertrophy outcomes um but yeah I
mean you you can you can analyze that
and metabolize it as you will um you
know you you could credibly make the
case that it does make it harder to
build muscle but maybe reduces rates of
muscle growth by about 50% or you could
say hey just du to differences in study
populations differences in training
interventions uh maybe it doesn't impact
muscle growth at all or if there is an
impact maybe it's smaller than
50% um the research doesn't support the
position that it makes it impossible to
build muscle certainly uh personally and
this is just kind of on a purely hunch
level I wouldn't be surprised if type 2
diabetes did make it like did have some
negative effect on hypertrophy of of
some magnitude um just because insulin
is implicated in amino acid uptake and
uh reducing catabolic signaling and also
glucose uptake so it may influence how
well you can get fuel to your muscles
during a training session and how well
you can bioenergetically recover from
training so you know maybe maybe the
effect would be smaller if you like
matched training interventions but maybe
uh having slightly better insulin
sensitivity could be superior in the
real world because it might let you
train a little harder and recover a
little better like like I'm I'm open to
all of that stuff like I I wouldn't be
surprised if there was some degree of
negative impact um but I also would be
surprised if that negative impact was
particularly large if it exists at all
um and again certainly it certainly it
doesn't make muscle growth impossible
like there's no reading of the research
on the topic that exists that would lead
one to that conclusion like it's um that
that is not an evidence-based takeaway
that is an evidence-free
takeaway um so yeah if you have type two
diabetes maybe there maybe there's a
negative impact but it certainly doesn't
make muscle growth impossible and if
there is an impact kind of the the
upward constraint on how large it is is
maybe it reduces it up to 50% although I
suspect the negative impact is quite a
bit smaller if it does exist um the next
part of that question was about
metformin whether that uh inhibits
hypertrophy
honestly like to answer this I will
first say um now we're talking about
pharmaceuticals I'm not a doctor I'm not
a pharmacist take everything I'm about
to say with a big grain of salt none of
it should be construed as medical advice
etc etc all standard caveat Supply um so
with met foran there was optimism that
it would actually help hypertrophy so
there was a study protocol
that that actually like got quite a bit
of buzz on social media a few years back
I think
2017 um which is kind of funny because
like a lot of studies themselves are
never read by anyone ever so the fact
that like a protocol for a study like
the study hadn't even been done yet but
just researchers were saying hey we're
we're pre-publishing this protocol about
a study we're going to do um it got it
got a lot of shares on social media made
some waves um and it was basically
proposing that met foran might improve
muscle growth in people with poor
insulin sensitivity so uh that that
protocol will be linked in the show
notes uh title was met Foreman to
augment training effective responses in
seniors parenthesis Masters study
protocol for a randomized control trial
um anyway so they published the protocol
then they did the study then that study
was published in
2019 and contrary to expectations met
Foreman did actually have a negative
impact on muscle growth um so that study
will be linked in the show notes title
was uh well it's it's the Master's trial
if you just search the Master's trial
PubMed I'm sure it'll pop up uh or again
just look in the show notes it'll be
linked um and so met foran
didn't uh didn't like ameliorate the
hypertrophic response altogether the
people who were taking metformin and
lifting did still gain some muscle just
not quite as much muscle as the people
who weren't taking metformin so it did
still seem to have it did seem to have a
net negative effect um in terms of why
that is the kind of go-to mechanism
would be related
Tok
phosphorilation um not to get too too
into the weeds but um amk and mtor if
you want to massively oversimplify
things ampk is sort of a master
signaling regulator for like aerobic
adaptations to
exercise um and what what metformin does
is it upregulates ampk signaling and uh
like an increase in insulin s an
increase in insulin sensitivity is
Downstream of that ampk up regulation
and so in some contexts amk can have an
antagonistic effect on mtor and again
massively oversimplifying mtor is kind
of like a master regulator of kind of
the the Upstream part of the hypertrophy
signaling Cascade so you know the the IM
the if if metformin has a negative
effect on muscle growth it's probably
its effects on ampk antagonizing the
mtor pathway kind of blunting those
hypertrophy responses there's been some
subsequent research looking at the
transcriptomic effects of metformin on
um like intramuscular signaling you know
finding that it impacts some of that
stuff there's also um some rodent
research at least suggesting that it may
um upregulate myostatin levels and
downstream myostatin signaling which can
have a negative effect on hypertrophy so
um yeah if if metformin does negatively
affect muscle growth those are some of
the current suggestions for like
mechanistic explanations for why that
would be
um but there is
also uh still some optimism in the
research and medical community that
despite that metformin could still have
positive effects on healthy muscular
aging like it might make it a little bit
harder to build muscle now but it might
help preserve muscle function um into
older age and people who are insulin
resistant um and also to make this
extremely clear there's not a ton of
research on it yet like there's there's
the Master's trial and I think there may
have been one other paper looking at the
impact of met Forman on training
adaptations um and so that that's why
I'm saying like if it has a negative
effect here are some of the mechanistic
explanations people are are working with
now um but I still wouldn't even be like
positive that it has a negative effect
again just because we're dealing with a
very very small body of research um but
the research currently does suggest that
it may have a small negative effect on
hypertrophy outcomes um but it does also
improve insulin sensitivity like it it
is a go-to treatment for type 2 diabetes
especially like early stage type 2
diabetes for a reason and that's because
it works really well for that purpose
and even if it does negatively affect
hypertrophy outcomes in the short term
um due to its positive effects on
insulin sensitivity it could still
improve healthy muscular Aging in the
longer term so um yeah I'm I'm not here
to make any recommendations about
whether [__] anyone should or
shouldn't take met foran um but yeah I
mean it it may negatively impact
hypertrophy but we would need more
research to confirm that for me to be
like super confident that it
does okay uh I think that answers that
question so let's move on to a question
from
Alexander hi guys so I was reading sort
of an old article uh titled size versus
strength how important is muscle growth
for strength gains and in it uh Greg you
write about how one of the contributors
to uh strength gains over time is uh the
effect hypertrophy has on uh the the
moment arm AR uh of our muscles and how
as those muscles get bigger uh that
moment arm becomes longer and more
advantageous and so I guess I was just
wondering um does that sort of mean as
sort of an extension from that that uh
getting a really sick pump would would
also
potentially lead to some short-term
strength gains due to the similar uh
like due to the increase
in muscle volume and therefore uh moment
arm all right I like I like how in-depth
this guy is thinking um Greg could you
explain a little bit more about where
that question might be coming from um
and what you talked about in that size
versus strength article uh sure yeah so
I I really liked this question because
it's a it's a it's a perfect combination
of of high brow and low low brow we're
going to talk about internal muscle
moment arms and the impact of getting a
sick pump which awesome I love that
combination uh so yeah where where this
question is coming from and this I will
note may not be the best topic for an
audio medium but uh dear listener close
your eyes and try to imagine this little
journey I'm about to take to to to just
explain where this question is coming
from so your biceps M run parallel with
your humorous and insert on your forearm
relatively close to your elbow and
they're inserting at an angle like your
your bicep is elevated a little bit so
that tendon is coming down and inserting
at an angle so just pict sure where that
tendon is inserting uh there on your
radius and just imagine like let's take
the biceps out of it all together now
and assume assume you have a string
attached to your bicep insertion and
it's pulling up perfectly in line with
your
humorous and think about that what that
would do to your forearm it wouldn't it
wouldn't make it Flex at all right like
it wouldn't cause elbow flexion because
it would just be pulling your radius
just right into the elbow joint so that
would not create a rotational moment to
cause elbow flexion um and it doesn't it
it wouldn't matter how hard you pulled
on that string
it wouldn't flex your elbow the way you
want your biceps to now imagine that
instead of being perfectly in line with
your humorus that that string was
perfectly perpendicular to your humorus
so if your arm is sticking straight out
at your side with your palm facing up
that string is inserting at your radial
tuberosity and pulling straight up
through the ceiling now when you pull on
that string it will Flex like it will
cause elbow flexion it will draw your
your radius up it'll cause your Forum to
move like that um and so that's
essentially what's going on here so your
your bicep is elevated up off of your
humoris it's inserting on your radius at
an angle and at least for getting elbow
flexion started the steeper that angle
is so the closer to being uh
perpendicular in this case being
perpendicular to your radius the more um
a given linear cont action of your
biceps will will contribute to creating
rotational moment at the elbow joint
okay makes sense it does make sense okay
so as muscles get bigger like as your
biceps and your brachialis get bigger
they go from being down closer to the
level of your humoris to being more
elevated and if you picture the tendon
kind of coming out right out at at kind
of in the middle of the end of that
muscle the bigger your muscles are
the the um less acute that insertion
angle would be so the greater distance
there would be between that tendon and
the middle of your elbow joint as the
muscle gets larger so that internal
moment arm is getting larger yep so not
only do you have more contractile units
in a larger muscle that help you curl
more weight also the leverage of the
muscle to create a rotational moment at
the joint is getting more Advan agous as
it gets larger okay you get it I hope I
hope the listeners got it too so that's
kind of the basis of this question like
it's it's a it's a it's a physics
question that internal moment arm gets
longer more advantageous as muscles get
larger so he's asking would that also
apply to getting a really sick pump your
muscles getting larger because of a pump
yes yeah and I don't see why it wouldn't
like I the I think it theoretically
could apply um but if only if what you
did to get a pump didn't also create
enough fatigue to mask the effect yeah
um cuz like getting a pump doesn't
acutely make your muscles that much
bigger like if you if they feel bigger
but they don't look that much bigger
right yeah like if if you got like 3%
better leverage due to a longer internal
moment arm but your muscles are now
fatigued 3% sure you're creating more
rotational torque than you would have if
you didn't have a pump but you're not
creating more rotational torque than you
would have if you were fresh because the
impact of the shifting moment arm is
offset by the impact of fatigue so
that's like a practical consideration um
another thing is it wouldn't necessarily
apply to every muscle so the uh article
um like the the study from bagotsky and
colleagues Linked In the size versus
strengths article was modeling things in
terms of the biceps um and you know the
verbal explanation I just gave was also
in terms of the biceps but not every
muscle has kind of that same
architectural relationship with the
joints that it crosses yeah so for
example think about the hamstrings and
how they insert on the isial tuberosity
like they're at the bottom of your
pelvis and they're they're basically
just coming straight up and inserting
there um so if you got like a sick
hamstrings pump
that's not necessarily going to change
the leverage your hamstrings would have
for for creating Hip Flex or hip
extension it might have a positive
impact on The Leverage they could create
for knee flexion yeah much in the same
way like the biceps elbow flexion but
you get a sick hamstrings pump that
wouldn't necessarily change those
internal moment arms for hip extension
the same way so you know if if this did
apply it wouldn't necessarily apply to
every muscle equally um and kind of of
go in a level up and and back to physics
it also wouldn't affect all like joint
ranges em motion the same way so
um you know what I'm not even going to
try to talk people through this you can
you can model it out for yourself or
kind of like draw Draw Something to like
help you think through this but
essentially it would have a larger
effect in more extended uh joint
positions and less of an effect or
potentially even a negative effect on
more flexed joint positions and like if
you've done a set of curls to failure
and like gotten a sick pump you've
probably even felt this like if you're
doing preacher curls as you get fatigued
like you can you can get it like you can
start the curl but then like the lockout
which is like really easy on your first
couple of reps gets harder and harder
and harder as you get more and more
pumped and I think part of that is just
the muscle itself is larger and so
there's kind of more compression between
the biceps and the forearms I wouldn't
be surprised if part of that as well
though is just that pump impacting like
like leading to a less advantageous
internal moment arm for elbow flexion at
uh High degrees of elbow flexion as as
the pump occurs um so yeah like it it it
would generally have a larger positive
effect at more extended joint angles
than more Flex joint angles
um
in in the case of flexors it would be
the opposite for extensors so like
triceps everything I just said flip it
around flip it and reverse it um perfect
so yeah uh to to answer Alexander's
question in a tldr type of way um yeah I
I don't see why if actual hypertrophy
did favorably impact uh The Leverage of
a muscle for creating joint torque I
don't see why getting a pump wouldn't
have the same effect effect but in the
real world because whatever you're doing
to get a pump is probably going to cause
some degree of fatigue as well it may
not actually be like you may not be able
to like measure the effect of the pump
itself like performance might still be
lower than it would have been even if
the muscle theoretically has like
slightly more advantageous
leverages okay that is it for the audio
questions let's move on over to Facebook
yeah so for these these were text based
questions so I am going to read them so
our first question is from Connor Smith
and Connor asked you've talked in the
past about Half-Life and clearance rates
for common stimulants like caffeine and
nicotine and how they can affect things
like Sleep Quality are these rates
largely independent of each other or are
they each metabolized more slowly when
they're both in your system is the same
true for other stimulants like ADHD
medications oh man um so this is a
question
that it's it's difficult to give kind of
blanket answers on because the the
actual answer is like it depends about
like it if if you're so let's abstract
the this question
like does consuming X impact the
clearance rate of Y um it largely
depends on whether those two things are
metabolized by the same enzymes and or
if either of them inhibit or facilitate
the activity of the enzymes that break
down the other one um and that is not
necessarily going to be the case for all
things that have the same effect on your
body though it will often be the case
for things that are structurally similar
um and things that are structurally
similar do often also have similar
impacts in your body but not always so
um with respect to
stimulants um caffeine nicotine and
amphetamine are all like structurally
quite dissimilar so like they they have
stimulatory net stimulatory effects in
the body but um they have slightly
different mechanisms of action and they
are just shaped kind of dissimilarly so
they're largely metabolized by different
enzymes um and specifically as it
relates to nicotine and caffeine um
there may be no effect or it might
actually be the opposite of what Connor
was asking about um so it may be that
that nicotine actually increases the
clearance rate of caffeine so increases
the rate that it's metabolized rather
than slowing it down so caffeine is
primarily metabolized by an enzyme well
there are multiple steps to how it's
metabolized but like kind of the most
important rate limiting step um is
carried out by an enzyme called
cytochrome P 4501 A2 so when people talk
about being a fast versus slow
metabolizer of caffeine and if you read
research on that um that's generally
what they're talking about they they're
looking at a variance of the cp12 gene
which is what codes for this enzyme um
and just like a particular alil codes
for a version of the enzyme that breaks
down caffeine faster than the other
version of the AL right um and so if
nicotine was also primarily metabolized
by cyp1 A2 then you might expect there
to be some competitive inhibition so
both of them kind of competing for the
same enzyme and so both of them being
ingested together um slowing down the
clearance rate for both but uh that is
not the case so nicotine is primarily
metabolized by two other members of the
cytochrome p450 super family of enzymes
uh cp2 A6 and C cyp 2 B6 um and a couple
others but those are those are the two
biggies um so yeah they're they're not
going to interfere with each other by
competing for the same enzymes nice uh
however nicotine like I said may
actually um instead of like slowing down
the clearance rate of caffeine may be
speeded up and the reason I say may is
nicotine may be an inducer of the cyp1
A2 enzyme meaning that it essentially
either incre increases the levels of
that enzyme or increases how fast that
enzyme works so it would break down
caffeine faster um and the reason I say
maybe is that still somewhat
controversial and um essentially so
cigarette smoking uh like the act of
smoking cigarettes definitely induces
the
c182 uh enzyme like it it speeds up how
quickly it works okay um but it's not
entirely clear whether that's due to
nicotine itself or due to some of the
other combustion products of smoking and
I think the way the research is current
ly leaning is that nicotine per se is
not the inducer but it's rather the the
combustion products of smoking I see but
I think that's still somewhat
controversial like I don't think it's
fully settled um so so probably caffeine
and nicotine have no effect on the
metabolism rates of each other but if
there is an effect it may it may be that
nicotine speeds up how quickly caffeine
is metabolized like I said it is
probably more the combustion products
than the nicotine itself um but yeah so
like if you've ever heard for instance
that grapefruit juice increases the
halflife of caffeine it's like a similar
type of effect but in Reverse so there's
a flavone in grapefruit called Narin
genin that inhibits the cp12 enzyme so
if you inhibit it you slow down how
quickly caffeine is metabolized so it
stays in your system longer it's like
inducing the enzyme is the same effect
but just in Reverse like it it speeds it
up
I actually had never heard that before
that's interesting oh huh that is
interesting yeah it's
um you know I think you're not you're
not quite enough of a stimulant junkie
maybe like f folks who get like really
in espe really into especially like
pre-workout yeah um often times they're
like ah man I don't necessarily want to
lose like I don't necessarily want to
use more caffeine and like burn out my
tolerance but like and I just want it to
stay in my system longer so like I'm
going to take my pre-workout and I'm
also going to like drink some grapefruit
juice to extend the effects of caffeine
that also this this is like an old
school one um that was one of the like I
think gym culture found out about that
from diet culture because that was one
of the things in like the grapefruit
diet oh God yeah cuz they're like oh
yeah like drink your morning coffee just
black don't add extra cream or sugar to
it and then eat that grapefruit and gu
what that's going to give you more
energy throughout the day you don't have
to eat and yeah and extend the appetite
suppressant effects effects of the
caffeine because you're getting the um
you're extending the half life of the
caffeine with the fruit uh anyway so
yeah that's just like that that's a
that's a tidbit that I think may have
been more known 10 years ago like that's
interesting when the grapefruit diet had
previously been more popular but yeah so
gra diet was popular like 30 years ago
Greg yeah yeah but but I'm saying like
there's like a cultural memory of it
like people did it in the 9s and so
folks still remember it in the remember
it a little bit less in the teens and
now remember it even less in the 20s you
know fair enough there's there's a
halflife for how long it takes people to
forget the effects of grapefruit On's
halflife uh very good so like this like
the the same general principle applies
to other stuff as well so like a lot of
drugs um we'll kind of say on the
packaging or like your doctor pharmacist
may tell you like uh don't consume this
with cruciferous vegetables or grilled
meats or licorish and it's for that
reason so c182 is involved in the
metabolism of a lot of stuff and in
particular a lot of drugs
heartbroken and uh so cruciferous
vegetables and grilled meats are c182
inducers whereas licorice is like a
crazy strong C i182 inhibitor um all of
which is to say that the the inhibitor
bit is like if you're if you're on the
tip of just drinking grapefruit juice to
extend the effects of caffeine if you
really want to extend the effects of
caffeine eat some licorice instead um
but yeah so that's because like they
they mess up um like doing guidelines
and assumed half- lives of drugs you may
be taking just because of their effects
on that
enzyme so um yeah tldr is that
nicotine probably doesn't have much of
an effect on the half life of caffeine
caffeine almost certainly doesn't have
much of an effect on the halflife of
nicotine but if there is an effect it
might be that nicotine actually makes
the half-life of caffeine shorter rather
than longer um because they don't use
the same enzyme and the the uh
facilitating versus like um inhibiting
effects of one on the other as for other
stimulants or just anything else where
you have any questions of this sort um
you just need to do some reading for
yourself and what I've tried to do in
this answer is give you a bit of a
framework
for knowing some of the things to look
at to start answering those questions so
basically look
into what like how a particular thing is
metabolized if you're interested in how
something else affects the metabolism of
that thing look to see if that other
thing is competing for the same enzyme
or if it uh induces or inhibits the
effect of that enzyme and then if you're
interested in adding a third thing into
the mix now you have a matrix of like
how are all of these things metabolized
and do any of these things have impact
on any of the enzymes metabolized in or
involved in metabolizing any of them you
add a fourth thing into the mix the the
complexity increases geometrically there
are people whose job it is to know these
things so it's yes and they're called
pharmacist exactly um and not only is it
their job to know to know these things
but
like it's complex enough that even they
often aren't expected to actually know
these things like they right they
memorize every possible permutation they
have software where you put in
everything somewh taking and yeah it
hits them with all of those interactions
that again there there are too many for
like anyone to keep in their mind um I
bet you could I no I I absolutely
couldn't um I like even even for this
like I knew the thing about Licorice and
uh cruciferous vegetables and grilled
Meats I couldn't remember which ones
were Inhibitors which ones were inducers
like uh and I I didn't know about the
bit about uh potentially nicotine or
more likely the combustion products of
cigarettes like there's there's a lot
there's a lot of this stuff you know um
so ask a pharmacist so they can plug it
into their software yeah ask a
pharmacist who may know and they
probably won't know but they have
software that could tell them yeah um or
if you're curious just really go down a
[__] Rabbit Hole of uh yeah make a
bunch of charts of of reading about rate
limiting enzymes lines between
everything yes but uh just as a general
principle you should not assume that
taking one stimulant will affect the
halflife of others right it may it may
make it longer it may not affect it it
may make it shorter it really just
depends on how each of those is
metabolized we have another question
from John in the Facebook group how much
can BMR vary between individuals can the
term Fast Metabolism be true
for example could a lightweight
individual with moderate activity
possibly have a higher BMR than someone
of the same size and
activity yes absolutely um so I wrote an
article for the macro Factor website
that will be linked in the show notes
the title was do people really have
quote fast metabolisms or quote slow
metabolisms and uh the answer to the
question posed in the article and the
answer to John's question question is an
unequivocal yes so um the way I went
about answering that question in the
article is like there there is this idea
that a lot of people have and and I in
the article I kind of dig into where I
think this idea may have come from but
people have this idea that uh the idea
like the concept of people having fast
or slow metabolisms is just like
[__] and something that that someone
would just say if they're trying to get
like come up with an excuse for why they
can't lose weight or can't gain weight
right um but but actually it all just
comes down to body size and body
composition and no one actually has a
slow metabolism and uh if you think you
do it's just because you're um
misestimating how much you eat and blah
blah blah like that's that's a really
common idea people have but when you
actually dig into the research you find
that no like there is a ton of
variability there and so the way I I
went about answering that question in
the article is essentially just looking
at the accuracy and um individual level
variability in in the accuracy of BMR
prediction equations because essentially
what those are the whole point of them
is you you actually measure someone's
BMR usually using uh indirect direct
calorimetry like looking at gas exchange
when people are are in a rested State
and you measure a bunch of things about
them like height weight age sex whatever
sometimes body
composition um you know various various
components of body composition maybe
throw some circumference measurements in
there um but essentially you're you're
trying and then you develop a multiple
regression equation to say once we
account for these differences like once
we
essentially to be able to compare to app
like four people of a particular body
composition body size activity level sex
age whatever um what would we predict
their BMR to be MH and then you plot
those predictions against their actual
bmrs and you can look to see how well
your your equation is performing and
just how much spread there is of those
errors from the predictions um and what
you tend to see is that uh like
confidence
intervals for those like individual
level errors essentially saying for two
people of the same size same activity
level same body composition whatever um
how much faster or slower might their
BMR be from what we would predict it to
be given all of the variables that go
into this equation
and what you tend to see is that the
confidence intervals there tend to cover
a range of around 800 calories um so in
other words if you quote unquote should
have a BMR of, 1500 calories given your
age sex size activity levels body comp
whatever there's about a 2/3 chance that
your actual BMR is somewhere between,
1300 and 1700 and about a 95% chance
that it's somewhere between 1100 and
1900 and that will be roughly normally
distributed so there will be more small
errors than like super large errors but
also when we're talking about 95% of
individuals we're not even talking about
outliers essentially if you had a 100
people in a room and they all had had
the same activity levels same body comp
they all weighed the exact same um and
and they were all like quote unquote
supposed to have a BMR of 1500 calories
there would be two to three people who
who would have bmrs of 1100 or less and
two or three people who would have bmrs
of 1,00 or more so you know we're we're
not even talking about one in 10,000
type of deals just nor variability
people who you're likely to find in a
room of 30 to 100 people um and yeah so
so most people don't have like super
faster super slow metabolisms but it's
not uncommon for people to have bmrs
that you think would be similar that
could vary by up to 800 calories which
is a pretty big difference significant
yeah um and going a level deeper fun
fact what I really enjoyed learning as I
was researching for that article because
like I I saw those findings and I was
like well this is pretty surprising like
I I mean it wasn't surprising because
like I had known about the relative
accuracy of BMR equations for a while
but I I like as I started thinking about
it more I'm like I don't know why this
is you know I I don't know what the
explanation for this thing is and so I I
did some more some more reading and uh
it seems like the primary contributor to
having a quote unquote fast or quote
unquote slow
metabolism is relative organ size yeah
which is kind of wild it is wild so your
your vital organs comprise well I mean
I guess like your internal organs
because like your muscles and like skin
like those are vital organs you you know
what I'm saying though you're saying
your livers your kidney your brains
lungs whatever brains plural brain okay
uh well left brain right brain you got
two of them
uh uh but yeah your your brain liver
kidneys heart lungs whatever they
comprise a relatively small percentage
of your total body mass but they account
for like three ERS of your basil
metabolic rate your your fat tissue and
your muscle tissue are are Far and Away
the two largest in bone those are far in
away the three largest contributors to
total body mass but they are
all not particularly metabolically
active tissues at rest muscle can be
super metabolically active during
exercise but at rest none of those
tissues are burning many calories at all
so um yeah Mo most of your BMR is just
driven by things like your kidneys and
liver and whatnot um and that's just is
it just like a larger organ like if your
brain is bigger or your liver is bigger
it's going to yes okay so there there's
also research on the uh relative tissue
specific metabolic rates of those organs
which tend to decrease a little bit with
age and can also within a particular age
bucket vary between individuals but that
variability isn't as large as just the
variability in size um kind of just
because it can't be you know like
you're your heart's got to be Harden you
know like if it's not if it's not really
puming that blood like something that's
not going to be good for you yeah U so
yeah like they're they're all just like
pretty pretty freaking metabolically
active all the time for everyone there
is some variability but not quite as
much but yeah like in general bigger
people tend to have larger organs but
it's nowhere close to a onetoone
relationship um the the tightest
relationship is with heart size and body
size but even there you're dealing with
like a correlation coefficient like an R
value of around 7 which means that body
size only explains about half of the
variability in heart size the um impact
of uh like the correlation between body
size and like kidney size or liver size
or the size of like pretty much any
other organ is considerably lower but uh
you probably haven't had a full body MRI
to estimate the volume and therefore the
mass of all of your internal organs I
would assume and so what BMR equations
do is they tacitly assume that all of
the metabolically active tissues that
are contributing
to Basil metabolic rate scale one to one
with body size like body size is a proxy
for the size of all of the things in
your body that are contributing to Basil
metabolic rate and body size is a pretty
good predictor of fat Mass it's a pretty
good predictor of muscle mass it's a
pretty good predictor of bone mass none
of which are all particularly
metabolically active but but organs are
a wild card yeah then the tissues that
are contributing the most to your
metabolic rate aren't as strongly
associated with body size chaotic I love
them all of which means yeah like two
people of the same size could have very
different bmrs like one could have a
quote unquote Fast Metabolism one could
have a quote unquote slow metabolism and
if you knew that one of them had a fast
or a slow metabolism you can make
predictions about their organ sizes from
that information which is like kind of
creepy creep somebody out yeah like if
you know if a BMR equation says that
someone should have a BMR of 1300
calories and and you get you get a mask
on them you know you you do some gas
exchange you measure their BMR and
instead of 1300 it comes out at 18800
you could be you could be like I bet
that person has particularly large
kidneys for their overall body size or
like a particularly large liver um
interesting so yeah uh I hope no budding
Han Hannibal lectors are listening to
this but if there are any no well don't
give them advice I mean whatever I can't
be we can't be held liable for this but
look if you want to enjoy someone's
liver with some fava beans and a nice
glass of Kean maybe try to get a job in
a metabolism lab and Jesus Christ look
for people whose bmrs are way higher in
the long game you think they should be
oh my god um anyway tldr to answer
John's question yes um bmrs can vary
considerably between people even people
who are the same size similar body comp
and that seems to primarily be related
to relative organ sizes that is such a
fun fact it's really good I think it's
really good for people to know too
because you can't control the size of
your organs like if somebody has a way
higher BMR and they're because they have
big ass organs and they're trying to
shame you being like Oh well you're just
not as good as me because your BMR is
lower it's like no you just have
freakishly large organs calm down
Cassandra I I don't think anyone out
here is doing hypertrophy training for
their kidneys and if you're doing hyper
that's bad yeah that's bad and if you're
doing hypertrophy training for your
liver it's probably doing more harm than
good right yeah don't do that
yeah okay let's go to the next
question from
Angela uh Angela asks is it possible to
taper down activity levels steps without
reducing calories if so what would be a
stepbystep way to do that I'm currently
at
25k plus and this won't be sustainable
soon yeah um a lot of steps I can
imagine that
does that does sound like a lot of steps
take a long time to get them in uh but
yeah so to to answer your question
Angela um is it possible to taper down
your activity levels without reducing
calories um I assume there is a tacid
assumption in this question that is can
you reduce calories without affecting
relative energy balance like if you're
trying to be in a particularly sized
Surplus or deficit or stay at
maintenance can you be less active keep
eating the same amount of calories and
stay in the same relative energy balance
I I assume that that is like an
underlying assumption here um and so to
to answer that question I'd say maybe to
some degree especially given how active
you currently are so one of the things
we've talked about on the podcast
several times before is the constrained
energy expenditure model from from
ponser and colleagues um basically the
idea is that there is not a onetoone
relationship between how much energy you
burn through physical activity and how
much your total daily energy expenditure
increases by for each increment of
additional physical activity so
essentially if you're very very
sedentary and you start exercising
enough to burn an extra 20 200 calories
per day your total daily energy
expenditure will probably go up by
around 200 calories per day like there's
a roughly linear relationship between
exercise energy expenditure and
increases in total energy expenditure as
you go from being sedentary to
moderately active but if you're already
very active say you're getting in 22,000
steps a day and you become more active
say you start getting in 25,000 steps
per day um just in theory those extra
3,000 steps what's that
probably
um what's 3,000 steps that's probably
about a mile give or take probably a
little more than a mile whatever let's
let's just say you're walking another
mile okay um and you're already that
active uh for an average exer Siz person
walking a mile that level of activity
should burn about 100 calories for
active energy expenditure but if you're
already that active it will probably
increase your total energy expenditure
for the day by less than 100 calories um
and if you're super super active the the
net increase might only be like 30
calories or something so um since you
are already so active if you stepped
back from 25,000 steps per day to 20,000
steps per day say the total energy that
you're burning through activity like it
it would be less than this but
theoretically let's just say it goes
down 500 calories per day you probably
wouldn't have to reduce your energy
intake by 500 calories per day because
your total daily energy expenditure
probably wouldn't go down by 500
calories per day might only go down by
200 so you would still need to reduce
your energy intake but only by about 200
um so yeah that's the first part of the
answer to that question um essentially
the degree to which you would need to
reduce your energy intake would be
disproportionately low relative to the
amount you reduced your activity levels
because you're already so active um that
would be my that's what I would
anticipate um but uh the next kind of
level to this answer is that you
probably will need to reduce your energy
intake but uh if if you do it probably
won't actually affect your perceptions
very much um so I I think a concern
people
have is they they get really active and
let's say they're they're maintaining
their weight on 3,000 calories a day and
they they feel okay and saded but like
they never feel stuffed they never feel
like that hungry and they they like how
they feel when they're eating 3,000
calories a day um and they're like ah
man but if if I become less active I
might have to go down to 2500 calories a
day and I know that if I was eating 2500
calories a day now I would feel hungry
and lethargic and not sated therefore
that concerns me and I would like to
become less active and still be able to
eat 3,000 calories a day but um appetite
regulation and and hunger perception
are closely linked to and coupled with
activity levels above a certain
threshold of
activity which is to say uh and this is
like conceptually similar to the
constrained energy model where it's a
nonlinear relationship and and what
happens with sedentary folks and
moderately active folks and superactive
folks it's it's not the same at all
activity levels so people who are
somewhere between moderately Act and
very active um there's there's good
coupling between hunger perceptions and
and appetite regulation signals and
energy expenditure so if you are
currently maintaining your weight on
3,000 calories a day and you're super
active and you you become less active
but you're still quite active and now
you're only burning 2500 calories per
day and so you need to eat 20 2500
calories per day to maintain weight
eating 2500 calories with that lower
activity level will feel about the same
as eating 3,000 calories with the much
higher activity levels because energy
expenditure and appetite are are well
coupled if you are at least moderately
active where that changes is if someone
is moderately active and then they
become quite sedentary so for for folks
who are quite sedentary there is a
decoupling between appetite perception
and hunger regulation and energy
expenditure such that you know let's
let's say now you're moderately active
you're eating 2500 calories per day
you're maintaining weight you still feel
pretty okay and you you just from that
point become super sedentary and so now
instead of burning 2500 calories per day
you're only burning 2,000 calories per
day it's not like when you step down
from 3,000 to 2500 you're you're when
you step down from 2500 to 2,000 you no
longer feel as saded um you might still
feel hungry and lethargic throughout the
day you're only burning 2,000 calories
per day but your appetite cues and your
hunger cues are trying to tell you to
eat maybe 2200 2300 calories per day so
um you know stepping down from 2500 to
2,000 and still trying to do that to
maintain weight would lead to different
perceptions and and make it like it it
would be more challenging to make that
reduction than from the 3,000 to
2500 um all of which is to say uh Angela
if
you're I totally understand that you
don't want to keep walking 25,000 steps
a day that is a shitload of steps um if
you wanted to dial that back
considerably like let's say to 15,000
10,000 um you will you will probably
need to reduce how much you're eating as
you do that um but that reduction like
it it's probably not going to hurt like
you're you're going to feel about the
same with your reduced calories as you
currently feel with how much you're
currently eating because you should
still stay in the activity range where
you have strong coupling between hunger
perceptions appetite cues and energy
expenditure as your energy expenditure
goes down you'll need to eat less but
you'll also naturally want to eat less
and eating a little bit less won't make
you feel worse but if you went from
255,000 steps a day to 2500 steps per
day and you reduce your energy intake
down to your new level of energy
expenditure at only 2500 steps per day
that would probably feel quite bad cuz
now you're entering sedentary territory
where you don't have that strong
coupling between
appetite perception and energy
expenditure
anymore all right moving over to Reddit
uh the most upvoted uh comment on on the
Q&A post and this got more up votes than
any comment got liked in the Facebook
group as well most popular thing across
either Community was from poken Pinoy uh
just saying all we like Lindsay um
Lindsay the the people have spoken um so
how will you answer for your crimes
abandoning the audience at this time
well I talked I talked about it at the
beginning I feel like I have a good
reason and we have a plan for people to
take care of the audience moving
forward um I feel like no one is more
heartbroken about this than my
dad that is so
true which honestly makes me a little
sad he loved the podcast so much while I
was on it I don't think he's going to
keep listening honestly but
um I'll just say it's very nice that
this was the most uploaded comment and I
as I said at the beginning of the
podcast I'm very grateful for the
support that I've received but you
specifically asked people if they had
any questions for me and there were none
that is true that is true so like I
don't have anything happening here
there's there's nothing for me to do
here other than just kind of go back and
forth with you which I've been happy to
do but I think uh the audience will get
more out of people who can answer these
questions in a similar level of depth
that you can
um so I guess that's my answer to the
alleged
crimes yeah that's that's that's fair
enough uh what you did mention though
about Rick um Rick since since this will
be the last episode of the podcast you
ever listen to um Ju Just wanted to give
you a quick shout out shout out Rick
Rubble uh best father-in-law a guy could
ask for uh you you raised a heck of a
woman and go
Bucks okay um let's let's let's move on
to the first actual question from Reddit
I'll read this question how do you in
incorporate Plyometrics and explosive
training for jump height for example
basketball athletes in the offseason is
it a separate block from hypertrophy and
strength a separate day in hypertrophy
and strength blocks or something else
yeah it's it's hard to just give like a
flat blanket answer to this question
because it's going to depend on several
things one is what sort of sport
training are they currently doing so the
question says basketball athletes in the
offseason but but often times there's
not really an off season um you know you
go straight from school ball to aou and
then you know maybe you have like an off
seon that you just need to recover for
like a month before the next season
starts back up so yeah you know you
might consider one of those your
offseason but you're still doing some
stuff or if you do have an offseason
you're still like going to camps there
there's Summer Ball like there's there's
practices going on is this for
professional
athletes um you're talking about like
high schoolers well like yeah I mean but
I'm just playing the numbers here
there's you don't think this guy on
Reddit is trading professional athletes
I strongly assume they aren't fair not
um yeah I mean if if you're talking
about training athletes and you're a
coach you're typically talking about
training high school athletes that
that's the bread and butter of the of
the athletic training industry um but
yeah I mean I mean often times there's
not a true offseason like like
basketball players are typically playing
ball year round um and whether or not
that's in some sort of competitive
league they're at least getting to the
gym working on some skills playing
pickup ball um and and that's going to
be relevant for what sort of plyometric
training they can do and benefit from
because basketball is a very plyometric
sport like you're hitting jump shots
you're jumping for rebounds you're
jumping to try to block people um and
like hard productive Plyometrics are
kind of tough on your joints kind of
tough on your tendons like totally safe
totally fine to do but um maybe not the
best to do super intensely if they're
also still playing like a fair bit of
ball which you know again like maybe
they're they're on the youth circuit and
basically playing year round or they
just love the game and so the season's
over but they're still getting out of
plane so uh it's going to depend on how
much of that they're doing because
that's going to determine how much like
just directed plyometric loading they
can handle and and benefit from and
adapt positively to um another relevant
question is just what else they need to
work on in their training so um one of
the things we've talked about on the
podcast quite a few times before is the
idea of the interference effect with
concurrent training um and how
specifically with regards to strength
and hypertrophy concerns of the
interference effect are probably a
little overblown so if if this is your
first time encountering those terms it's
the idea that doing aerobic training and
uh like strength training or resistance
training in tandem the the interference
effect is the idea that doing that will
lead to reductions in Anor robic
outcomes like hypertrophy strength gains
power output um versus only doing
resistance
training um and so that that concern is
mostly overblown as it relates to
strength and hypertrophy like if doing
some some cardio like some running
negatively impacts muscle growth and
strength gains the impact is probably
relatively small but the interference
effect with concurrent training is quite
large when it comes to power based
outcomes so Plyometrics like you're
you're trying to increase jump height
you're trying to increase power output
if someone in the last season was like a
skilled player but they're getting
gassed in the third quarter and so a big
focus of the off season is trying to
build up that gas tank so they can
actually like really really go at it for
like 28 to 36 minutes a game or whatever
um you're probably not going to get
quite as much out of the Plyometrics you
do because you're also really focusing
on aerobic conditioning season um or uh
kind of on the flip side you might have
a player who is already plenty strong
and and quite muscular but not
particularly explosive and so maybe for
a lot of your ba your basketball
athletes are like oh man how am I going
to balance the plyos I want them to do
with heavy squats heavy split squats
heavy step-ups whatever like the stuff I
need to do to help them build the muscle
and strength base with this athlete
they're plenty muscular they're plenty
strong already we don't need to do that
much heavy resistance training maybe we
can have them do more plos because
that's you know helping address the
thing where they currently suffer so you
know th those are some of the questions
you need to ask yourself just how how
much plyometric Sports specific stuff
are they already doing and what other
demands like what what other physical
conditioning demands are you trying to
meet in the offseason and would that
facilitate plos or would that work
against it so you know th those are just
kind of things in the initial
calculus um often times though the best
option and you know here again I'm
assuming you're training high school
kids who might be coming to you three
maybe four times a week maybe two times
a week probably not every day um often
times just given the the constraints of
how that coaching relationship tends to
work the best way to set it up is you
just do
plios before their other training yeah
and if they're coming three times a week
you probably don't want to have three
hard plyo workouts a week but generally
in one or two of those sessions you just
do the plios at the start of the session
um you they need to be done when the
athlete is fresh and able to give it
their all like they're not already pre
fatigued um and on the flip side and and
thankfully um doing like a tough plyo
workout might reduce how much people can
lift on subsequent exercises they do but
if if they do the impact probably won't
be particularly large and sometimes you
even see like a facilitation effect like
you you really get the nervous system
like fired up and and going good with
some plios and then you get them under a
bar and they lift better than they would
have just after a standard warm-up so um
yeah usually if you're going to do plos
with other things you typically want
them to be first often times just cuz
you're not seeing the athlete every day
you're going to need to do them with
other things so just warm up plyos get
onto the other stuff um so yeah just do
it at the start of a workout when you
would be doing other stuff and those two
questions I pose to start with what does
their Sports specific training look like
and what else do they need to work on
that's going to influence the type the
amount and the intensity of the plyos
that they're doing at the start of their
session so you know know if if they're
not doing that much conditioning work
they're not doing that much kind of like
plyometric Sports specific training um
they can maybe do more plyos at the
start of the workout versus if uh I mean
whatever like if if you've been coaching
like you you you know where I'm getting
out with this um you know if if they
need to do more plyos and can benefit
from more plyos they're still doing it
at the start of the workout it's just
higher intensity maybe higher volume if
they're you know doing a lot of sports
specific training a lot of plyometric
stuff they're doing a lot of
conditioning work and you're still
working in pios just less intense plyos
lower volume of them either way it's
going at the start of the workout that
tends to get the job done um the
two uh uh like pieces of advice and like
the two mistakes that I would recommend
looking out for to make sure you avoid
is like a a classic like rookie coach
move is to have is to put plos on an off
day um where it's like hey look like
we're we're doing some like hard
conditioning work we're really getting
it we're really getting at after it in
the weight room we're doing some heavy
training we're doing some high volume
hypertrophy training um and Pio like
that's that's just jumping you know
like if you do a really tough really
intense plyometric
workout your knees might be a little bit
sore the next day potentially or that
could suggest that you overdid it a
little bit but like you know you might
have like a little joint soreness but
you're not going to get like crazy
delayed onset muscle soreness from it um
it feels like it should just be easier
than most other training you're doing um
and so a mistake a lot of rookie coaches
make is they're just like hey the plos
aren't as hard as squats and like we're
trying to get a lot done in this
offseason so like when when you come to
me you're going to do
you know the the tough stuff and then on
your own time like going to write you a
plyometric like a Plyometrics workout
and you're going to do that on your off
days don't [__] do that like that's
that's a bad plan um because one that's
really intense tendon and Joint loading
yeah when you're hopefully wanting those
tissues to recover right and especially
if you're dealing with youth athletes
like man a lot
of a lot of lot of kids are like 17 18
and like their knees and ankles are
already in bad shape just from yeah like
specializing in a sport too young
playing aou year round like it's it's
bad news like if they have off days like
really encourage them to rest and relax
yeah um and plos are one of the worst
things you could do on an off day oh no
I feel like this is super common though
uh it's it's not uncommon yeah um but
yeah don't don't do that don't do that
that's bad um and the other thing is
you're saying that someone's doing plyos
but they're doing cardio that involves
jumping um so like plyometric
training the the classic Plyometrics are
depth jumps so you know depending on how
explosive someone is depending how
strong they are you know they might just
be jumping down like stepping down from
like a 4in platform maybe it's a a foot
tall platform um some like hyper
explosive uh like jumping athletes like
like high jumpers or triple jumpers or
um like throwers are also like crazy
explosive shot discus throwers sometimes
you see like really high depth jumps
from some of those athletes you
generally don't need to go crazy on the
height for um for like younger like less
Elite athletes but you know essentially
you're stepping down off of something
minimizing ground contact jumping back
up as high as you can um and you know
you're not just
dropping gradually absorbing the contact
squatting down jumping up like it's it
it Pio should be violent like that
because you're you're trying because
you're trying to generate as much power
in the shortest period of time as
possible like that's that is the name of
the game for
uh like increasing jump height or even
just like increasing onc cord
explosiveness like it's not just how
much power can you gradually wind up to
it's how much power can you create and
how quickly can you create it and
especially absorb force and then kind of
retransmit like that's that's what
you're doing it should be intense it
should be violent um if someone is doing
a set of 20 it's not plyometric anymore
like you you have to do it fresh and you
have to be able to give it your all so
yeah plos on off days no bueno um doing
just a bunch of low intensity jumps and
because it's jumps you're calling it
pios that's not even plios at that point
it's cardio um so yeah those are two of
the most common mistakes to avoid but
yeah just to go back to the answer to
the question typically you just do it
before your other training um with the
type and amount dictated by the level of
the athlete and what other training
they're doing and what else you're
trying to work on in the offseason okay
um and I forgot to shout out the person
who asked that question the Reddit
username was
trer our next question is from no
performer 8133 on Reddit it just feels
so silly reading out those names it's
fine whatever here's the question I was
listening to Arnold talk about getting
older and how he can't or won't do
certain stuff one of those being that he
doesn't seem to brace too heavily
because of the stress it puts on your
body my question is this is there any
research showing damage to the blood
vessels or whatnot in the longer term
due to the blood pressure increase
because of bracing or Val Sala
maneuver that's a good question and in
terms of direct research no not really
so ideally you would
have I don't know like a 30e study on
powerlifters um compared
to uh controls that are matched in terms
of demographics and maybe even do
resistance training but nothing
involving the valal the maneuver like
really heavy bracing and uh you would
try to control for confounding variables
as good as possible and then look to see
like vascular Health how it progresses
over time and where they start where
they ended up in 2030 years like that's
that's what you would love that study
does not exist I'd be surprised if it
ever exists um so yeah there's no direct
research on that question as far as I'm
aware um one thing I would note is that
there is a difference between things
that would negatively influence vascular
health and
things that maybe would exacerbate
problems if you already have poor
vascular health so you know for for
instance if you H if you have some sort
of condition that is exacerbated by
blood pressure spikes one of the common
pieces of advice that your doctor will
probably give you is to avoid the Val
Salva maneuver and they are right don't
do that like because that does yeah that
does quickly spike your blood pressure
and so if you have some sort of
condition that is sensitive to
elevations and blood pressure that's bad
but that doesn't necessarily therefore
mean that the Val Salva maneuver and
spiking your blood pressure like that
would lead to the deleterious changes
that would then at some point make it
dangerous to do the Val Sala maneuver
like if that makes sense it's it's the
it's this it's a similar idea of like
you know if you
um if you like do squats like that's
fine like it's good for you it's not
going to like mess up your knees or
anything but like if you uh just
ruptured your patellar tendon and had it
reattached maybe you shouldn't do heavy
squats you know yeah like the fact that
doing heavy squats would negatively
impact your recovery there doesn't
therefore mean that heavy squats will
cause you to rupture your patellar
tendon you know what I mean like that
that General principle so um yeah yeah
anyway like there are absolutely
conditions that uh like older lifters
may experience that would be exacerbated
by the blood pressure spikes associated
with the Val Sala maneuver but that
means that doing the Val Sala maneuver
is dangerous for those folks it doesn't
necessarily mean it's dangerous in
general like that's that's what I'm
saying um but what I will also say is
there is indirect research that is maybe
relevant maybe not but I feel like in
the interest of trying to answer this
question I should mention it um so there
there's epidemiological work on
occupational heavy lifting and so that
is
typically you're picking things up that
are somewhere between 10 and 50 pounds
multiple times per day every day um so
it's not you know it's it's less about
doing 500 lb deadlifts for like 10 total
reps twice a week and more about doing
50 lb deadlifts 500 times a day for 40
years you know um like it's it's those
are two very different things yes um but
within the context of Occupational heavy
lifting there is some research
suggesting that there might be increased
rates of es schic heart disease and all
cause
mortality um however it's hard to know
if that's due to confounders potentially
so you know often times you're
comparing um I mean you're you're often
comparing people who have like manual
labor Blue Collar jobs who might be of
generally lower socioeconomic status who
may have like worse access to the
medical system
um you know just dealing with all of the
other confounders that are generally
associated with socioeconomic status
so and you know with good
epidemiological research you try to
statistically adjust for as many
confounders as possible but can you do
it completely always uh who knows maybe
maybe not um so yeah like there's it
it's hard to know if that finding is due
to confounders or due to the
occupational lifting itself and and it
is also so hard to know or even like
come up with a goodfaith guess at
whether those findings would generalize
to lifting because lifting a 50 lb box
500 times a day and lifting 500 lbs a
total of 20 times a week those are those
are just radically different things um
so yeah like there's some indirect
epidemiological research on epid on
occupational heavy lifting that may
suggest that lifting that maybe involves
bracing along time could maybe like
negatively influence your risk of
esemicolonr evant research we have which
isn't particularly close isn't
particularly relevant but that is the
closest I can get to answering that
question okay I think we have just one
or two
more this next one is from Tampa
01 how much isolation work is too much
after doing the main compounds how many
extra sets of forearm calves rear delt
side delt biceps and core is enough but
not too
much
uh
it there's no way to get like a one-
siiz fits-all answer to that question um
I mean it's going to come down to like
preference time constraints ability to
recover and whether or not you're seeing
the outcomes you're interested in um
like if you if you want to be a freak
you know like you you don't have any
time constraints your life is built
around just getting as jacked as
possible and uh yeah that's what you're
doing you know um
you it probably wouldn't hurt to do
quite a bit of isolation work after your
compound exercises like there aren't
that like um Tampa called out some like
particularly good muscle groups to
mention here like forearms calves rear
delts side delts biceps core like if
you're doing a a diet of just rows
pull-ups squats deadlifts beninge press
overhead press like
you might you're you're going to be
getting some some forearm work for grip
but like you're not getting any like
wrist extension stuff you're not getting
any um like finger extensor stuff like
for your forearms and you're getting the
the wrist flexor training for your
forearms where in so far as some wrist
flexors are also finger flexors but like
yeah you could work in some wrist curls
as well like there's there's plenty of
stuff for your forearms you could be
doing that isn't NE necessarily being
covered by your heavy compounds same
thing for your Cales like your calvs are
engaged in squats and deadlifts um but
you know that's not as much as doing
direct calf raises rear delts they're
getting some work from your rows they're
not being like directly targeted side
delts they're getting some work from
your overhead pressing could also
probably do with some more like you you
get the point um so yeah like you you
have quite a few muscle groups that
aren't being directly stressed that much
with your heavy compounds you probably
could do quite a bit of um accessory
work for and there are also other
muscles that like you are hitting pretty
hard with your compounds but like maybe
certain like heads or regions aren't
being addressed with your heavy compound
so like good example I forget the
researchers name right off the top of my
head but in like 2018 2019 or so there
was a paper comparing uh triceps
extension to bench press for triceps
growth and they seemed to cause pretty
similar overall triceps growth but the
triceps extensions I think they were
doing Skull Crushers in that study were
way better at at growing the long head
of the triceps than the bench press was
so you know you're probably getting
plenty plenty of General work for your
triceps if you're just doing pressing
exercises and don't do like isolation
movements but H it probably wouldn't
hurt if you're trying to absolutely
maximize triceps growth to do some
isolation work to get the long head and
so like that's that's like broadly
generalizable same thing would apply to
hamstrings like you're getting plenty of
hip extension work probably do some knee
flexion work as well basically if you're
trying to cover all of your bases and
you don't have any other concerns or
time constraints there's there's a lot
of compounds you could or there's a lot
of isolation work you could be doing
um but if your goal isn't just to
absolutely maximize muscular development
and get as jacked as possible and spend
you know a decent chunk of your free
time in the gym you also don't have to
do all of that and so how much isolation
work would be too much for that
individual [__] any isolation work
you know like there's none of it you
absolutely have to do so that's kind of
the first the first filter like what are
you trying to accomplish here and what
do you what what would you need to do to
accomplish that balanced against how
else do you want to be spending your
life like do do you want to invest that
time and effort into it or would you
rather be doing something else um the
next filter is ability to recover
so um this is this is I will admit less
of something that I can point to a
direct reference for and more of just
like an experience and Vibes thing but
like I think you have local muscular
recovery capacity but also like Global
recovery capacity
um so like for instance if you like just
as a simple illustration if you never
did any lower body training I think you
could probably train your upper body
harder than if you were doing both upper
and lower like if if you're pushing both
as hard as you can and you're training
both upper and lower body um there will
come a point where if you push your
upper body work a little bit harder you
would be unable to recover from it
whereas if you just dropped leg training
entirely you could bump your upper body
training up that little extra Notch
right uh and still be able to recover
even though
you're yeah I mean you get the point
like I think there's both local and
Global recovery capacity and so at some
point when you are trying to do more
work for those muscles that maybe are a
little neglected from your compounds you
might start running into recovery issues
that seem
somewhat counterintuitive where it's
like hey like I started doing more
forearm calf rear delt side delt B in
biceps training and now like I find I'm
not recovering quite as well for my
squats like that doesn't make sense but
like who knows maybe it does like so
there there are potential recovery
constraints globally and also with those
individual muscles so even if you're not
running into Global recovery capacity
ability like you shouldn't do more calf
work than your calves can recover from
you know what I mean like that pretty
simple um and then yeah are you seeing
the outcomes you're interested in or not
um and is that related to maybe needing
to do more or having issues with
recovery and maybe needing to do less
and put all of that together and how
much isolation work is too much it could
be any it could like it could be that
any is too much it could be that a ton
is too much it really just depends on
all of those things um so yeah tough to
tough to give a blanket answer to that
question just in general though for most
people most of the time if I had to give
just a a blanket across the board
recommendation for this stuff I'd say
muscles that aren't targeted like super
hard by your um like your main compounds
and and Tampa I think did a really good
job of of laying out what most of those
would be forearms calves rear delts side
delts biceps core I potentially toss
traps in there as well I'd potentially
toss hip flexors very slept on uh
surprisingly large muscle and if you're
doing a ton of hip extension work
anyways may as well do some stuff for
your hip flexors I'd maybe throw neck in
there I'd maybe throw traps in there you
know you have maybe a dozen muscle
groups that you're not like really
targeting super hard with the main
training you're doing and I think if you
just wanted to cover all bases and like
get a good stimulus on them like very
low chance that you're overdoing it um
and if you're leaving some gains on the
table you're probably not leaving that
many I'd say try to do two or three
relatively challenging sets about twice
a week and you should be good to go
because most of those muscles will still
be getting some work from the compounds
you're doing so you know if you're if
you're doing you know four sets of rows
and four sets of pull Downs twice a week
you don't also need to do another 16
just direct sets for your
biceps uh over the course of the week
maybe like six to eight would be plenty
who knows whatever but yeah like two
three four sets once or twice a week for
those muscles that are a little bit
neglected that'll get you most of the
gains shouldn't take all that long
shouldn't be particularly difficult to
recover from so that doesn't directly
answer the question of how much is too
much but like how much would I generally
recommend to most people most of the
time two to four sets once or twice a
week for those like Pudo pseudo
neglected muscles that'll that'll get
you in pretty good shape
nice all right uh last
question for this podcast and last
question for Lindsay's run of the
podcast and in the Facebook group and
subreddit I did say that this was your
last episode and so if anyone had any
questions for you this was their last
time and this this was the Lindsay
question that came in so I figure in
respect for you and for the the person
who listened to the assignment we
should we should close on this one okay
okay hey guys I always see Greg putting
up a bunch of cooking stuff on Instagram
so this question is primarily for
Lindsay but I suppose you could answer
for each other um what's the favorite
thing that Greg has ever cooked and the
least favorite thing that Greg's ever
cooked for you he did say we could
answer for each other so you could
answer what your favorite thing I've
ever cooked for you is that's true which
is probably like five total things ever
um yeah but it was addressed to you so
you can go first
man this is this is
tough um
I'm looking at your Instagram right now
to look back through your little stories
I don't put most of what I I know you
don't do it as much
anymore
so almost everything you cook for me is
delicious there have
been I I think most of the things that
like stand out and terms of just like I
love this it's my favorite thing are
like kind of the more boring things like
you made me a pizza a couple weeks ago
that was just
like pepperoni and basil I think or
maybe just basil and tomato and it was
like it it reminded me why I love to be
alive it was so
good
[Music]
um
and you've made like some really good
chicken chicken and rice like the
Biryani chicken and rice that we made at
in the mountains one time when we were
on vacation that was really really
good um the cookies and cream ice cream
is one of my favorite
things um in terms of like what I you
make me the same thing on my birthday
every year you make me a steak and white
pesto pasta so most of these are just
like very simple things that I think are
just executed so perfectly and I love
them um when I think of least favorite
like honestly nothing comes to mind I
feel like you are you have a much better
memory for the things you've made that
didn't turn out great than I do oh I
have a perfect memory of everything I
made that didn't turn out we went to
Hmart the other day and when we were
driving home we were talking about how
there was some sort of stock or liquid
for making ramen noodles and you
mentioned that you had tried to make
ramen noodles like two or three years
ago and they turned out poorly um and I
had to like dig through my memory to
find that because like I just don't
remember um the bad things that you
make but you do make some pretty heinous
[__] for
yourself yes um so that's not stuff that
you make for me but sometimes you make
yourself a plate of food and I'm like
that is disgusting I would never eat
that and it's mainly just because
there's no Aesthetics involved when you
make yourself food you love to cut food
up small and mash it all together yeah
and make a brown mush yeah um because it
gets all of the it you get all of the
flavors in every bite I don't I don't
like
that sometimes I have to leave the room
because I'm so
disgusted yeah the the the difference
there is when I'm cooking for you I'm
cooking for someone I love and when I'm
cooking for myself I just need to eat
something and that's an
inconvenience
yeah that's fair I mean you can eat
whatever you want but it's it looks
really gross um I'm just I'm just
thinking I'm I'm just going to list
things now you made really good General
so chicken before I love a fried chicken
any sort of any sort of fried chicken
dish the Mamon Curry you made a couple
years ago um oh that was good I think
about that a lot that was super super
good we should make that
again
um I think that's all that's all I got
for now you make me bread all the time
too and you've made me a lot of great
breads um faka is probably my favorite
when you make a faka with some little
cherry tomatoes push down into it
delicioso well thank you baby
um
I wish I would have thought about more
since you listed so many things um but
in said favorite and least favorite and
so I you know I
I we you know this about me I approach
everything as if I'm taking a
standardized test like what is your
brain is broken in that way what is the
question asking for and how can I
maximize my chances of getting full
marks on this um so favorite thing I
really like the um the chicken schwarma
that you make oh yeah um it is very good
it's just an oven roasted chicken charma
yes but it's very good I just want to
clarify that I'm not putting things on a
spit and like doing it old school but if
you did that would also be very good I'm
sure probably I do not have that
technology though um we could we could
get one but that's not necessary I
wouldn't mind having a spit I we could
talk about that later okay
um and least
favorite that's also tough
because you mostly follow recipes right
and you follow recipes very well and
most recipes are written competently so
nothing is going to come out
particularly poorly
um I do
think I forget exactly what it was it
was some sort of like quick bread or
something but you made something like
you you've underbaked something fairly
significantly one time maybe it was a
the blueberry Buckle I don't remember
whatever I actually still enjoyed it cuz
I do like underbaked baked goods I don't
care about food safety but um yeah like
all of your stuff comes out good and
that's the only time I can think of that
you made something that like maybe
didn't turn out great although I've also
turned rice to complete mush before and
served that to you yeah but I also like
I like mushy that's true we did just
talk about how you made it more mushy
you made it more mushy and I like I like
that dude I'm going to absolutely cook
as like an old person like once once I
start losing in my teeth and it's like
ah you got to everything you cook just
has to be like mushed and homogenized
now and else you're going to have such a
head start on everyone they're going to
be like everyone's like oh no I'm going
to miss all of the lovely textures and
I'm like Haha I've been preparing for
this my whole life now I finally have an
excuse and no one can judge me for it um
oh my gosh yeah I I like mush you love a
mush yeah
um but yeah yeah most most of the stuff
you I I do really enjoy but the the
chicken charm is my favorite nice thank
you all right I think that does it for
this episode of the podcast Lindsay do
you have any any final words and
thoughts to share with final words with
all of your
fans yeah signing off I feel very
confident that we're leaving you in
great hands and that you're going to
enjoy the new lineup of pack and Milo
and Greg and I will still be here in
spirit likely in the Next Room over for
where Greg is recording so I'll I'll
still hear him talking I'll still be in
the Facebook group on the
subreddit um I'm the one who does the
Instagram so if you want to say
something nice you can send me a DM on
Instagram to cut through all of the spam
that we
get but I have really
enjoyed this time on the
podcast with you Greg and I am very
grateful for the support and if you miss
me just listen to the aspartame episode
it's enough content to last you a
lifetime and I have enjoyed doing it
with you uh it has been a blast but for
the last time with this current hosting
lineup uh we're signing off thanks for
listening to this episode of The
Stronger by science podcast we will be
back in two weeks with Milo and pack and
uh we're we're very excited for all of
the changes that have already occurred
and everything else that is to come in
2024 stay tuned watch this space there
is The Best Is Yet To
Come Oh my God uh yes so Lindsay
mentioned we mostly only get uh just
like spam messages to the the inbox of
the stronger by Instagram account like
it's it's mostly just like [__]
hustle grind set people who are just
like hey do you need new write marketing
emails I'm like no I know how to write a
marketing email it's my whole job yeah
can I send over a bespoke email sequence
I wrote for you like no and they're like
17 years old yeah it's like shut up you
have no idea what you're doing um but
yeah that's like all of the messages we
get on the stronger by science Instagram
account so if you know what reference he
was
making message the account and
um oh man I wish I you know what uh if
you don't currently have
a um if you don't if you don't have a
copy of Art and Science of lifting and
you're one of the first three people
that understood what reference Lindsay
was making because that's that's a deep
cut that
I think you need to have your
your brain's like a little bit broken if
you understood what that was immediately
and if so we love and appreciate you and
first three people to message the the
business Instagram account and say what
that reference was we'll we'll hook you
up with a free
book okay okay bye guys bye
[Music]
guys